I mean I got a friend of mine it may he
made 17 million dollars last year that's
hard to get your head around and so he
goes and buys um what was that car it
has a crystal ashtray it's crazy was
that thing oh it's an Aston Martin he
bought an Aston Martin four hundred and
thirty five thousand dollars or
something like that I'm like I can't get
my I can't get my breath he pulls the
thing up in the driveway now it's sweet
I can't get my breath though I cuz my
brain just does not you know what I'm
saying and if I don't watch I say out of
my mouth Wow
whoever needs that now you need to
understand fifty I'm uh seventeen
million dollars I'm gonna put in the
calculator here just for the fun of it
let's see here seventeen million I mean
I did that wrong so four hundred and
thirty five thousand dollars so I won't
see what percentage it is because it's
just it's nothing y'all is what it is
okay alright it's less than three
percent okay so here's the deal that's
like somebody making a hundred thousand
dollars a year buying a three thousand
dollar car when he bought that 435
that's the ratios right and so would you
ever tell somebody that was making a
hundred grand they couldn't drive a
three thousand dollar car they paid cash
for it no I think it arrived a three
thousand dollar car off the cliff every
third week and still be okay right and
the same is true of his poor hundred
thirty five thousand well he could feed
a lot of starving children for that well
I happen to know this guy and he feeds
more starving children every year than
you ever will in your entire freaking
life so you should shut up even though
he's driving that car so you really you
know the point is it's really it's
really difficult to manage other
people's business well you need to mind
your own business because most of us
have a perception problem you know you
take some guy that's worth two billion
dollars a billion is a thousand million
I can't get my head around that he's got
two of those two thousand million
dollars and he bought Visor I know what
one of those guys he bought a fifty-two
two million dollar jet I bet my brain
does not work like that but again you
want to run those percentages it's
nothing he could crash one of those jets
every other week and it wouldn't affect
nothing except for the people that was
on them right but I mean it just he
could just walk out there and shoot
holes in it if he wanted to it wouldn't
be a big deal it would be kind of crazy
but I mean but I just because I can't
get my head in my emotions around his
business doesn't mean he's out of line
it means my perspective is not there so
before you criticize somebody that is
spending the percentage of their income
that you'd spend on a biscuit you need
to stop and think about your perspective
on things it's hard for all of us this
is the Dave Ramsey show
you